well tom brady posted a video yesterday
that caught my attention where he says i
love talk radio and it was clips of all
the different people who were saying
he's washed up and gronk's washed up and
he doesn't look good and it's all all
stuff from throughout the 2020 season
and then he rubs it in everyone's face
that they won the super bowl and my my
reaction was now do one with all the
over-the-top media praise for the
quarterback after a super bowl that was
won by the defense because that's
precisely what happened and miles i will
stand by this till the day i die and
beyond if you flip patrick mahomes and
tom brady in super bowl 55 the
buccaneers still win the game and it's
worse than 31-9
oh that's yeah yeah i mean that that's
there's no doubt about that i'm actually
kind of surprised just said that
obviously but yes no there's no doubt
because look the buccaneers defense was
tremendous in that game and yes they did
get some good throws out of tom brady
but i think mostly they just had a good
scheme and a good plan and they just you
know kicked the the holy hell out of the
jeeps i i don't i don't know how else to
say it the chiefs didn't even get into
the end zone so yeah that defense won
that game and you know it just is what
it is but you know just call him tom
petty man he's free falling and you know
that's the kind of thing that he wants
it's true
look um
i've got i've got i've got multiple
problems with with what he did yesterday
i mean first of all first of all and i'm
going to forget them
so hopefully they'll all come back to me
but the first one is this
talk radio
look we're filling content every day and
we're going to react when you have a bad
game and news flash tom you didn't have
19 or 20 great games you had this moment
right that wasn't part of the video that
he put up when he's showing four fingers
he had a bad nfc championship he was
horrible for three straight drives he
threw interceptions he tried to blow the
game not that he tried to but he had
interceptions on three straight games if
the defense doesn't bow up they do lose
that game to the green bay packers think
about that headline the next day if they
had been up 28 to 10 and blown the game
because of three tom brady interceptions
one of which was just the hey i'm 43
it's like the old you wouldn't hit a guy
with glasses you wouldn't hit a guy
who's 43. i better throw the ball before
somebody hits me and that's fine he's
the man in the arena i respect him for
that i just don't i don't
it just rubs me the wrong way like i
don't want the guys who have become the
best ever to act like this it is petty
it is short-sighted i mean we're here
every day not that it's actual work but
we promote the sport we we hype the
legend and we give him his due when he
is deserving of it and he was
incessantly praised after the super bowl
oh and by the way
you've won the super bowl we saw you
throw the trophy from one boat to the
next shouldn't that be enough why do you
have to come back a week later with a
very selective glimpse at the
justifiable at the time criticisms of
the games where you weren't very good
what do you gain from that i just
thought the whole thing was weird and
it's beneath him that's my bottom line
he's better than that or maybe he isn't
no you like i said mike he's tom petty
he just wants you to stop dragging his
heart around okay
is that too hard look i i think that
whenever tom brady starts talking about
these kinds of things it's interesting
because he always creates a straw man
like from a couple of years ago when he
started talking about when he was still
with the patriots so everybody says we
suck and we can't win any games
the chargers when they beat the chargers
nobody believed in this who who's nobody
everybody believed in you
exactly who was saying that i don't know
who was saying that at all everybody
still thinks that you can win games tom
brady it's just you who has to create
this perception or whatever it is in
your mind that people are against me and
we saw this in the last dance with
michael jordan right you know i and i
took that personally and now it's just a
huge meme whatever it is that makes
these guys great and whatever it is that
they get in their mind that somebody is
against me and i've got to make sure
that i stick it to them i i it works for
them clearly but i tend to agree with
you that it should be beneath them
yeah and it's it's funny because
i tweeted what i tweeted and people
reacted and it's amazing how many ardent
tom brady fans there are
out there who took issue with my
observation chris sims somehow got
injected into the conversation people
think that chris has an unreasonable
dislike for tom brady so someone
that's just
awesome
oh that's great that's great uh
a little baby chris with his hands on
the trophy just like when he was five
years old and his dad won the trophy
with the new york giants um but i i just
i i just don't get it and you're right
miles it may be as basic and as
fundamental as when you've climbed the
mountain that many times you need to
find motivation wherever you can and if
you need to embellish and or fabricate
it you do it michael jordan did it he
admitted it all that matters is what you
think and whether it's a straw man or
whether it's a real thing whatever you
can do to get yourself
rolling out of bed at 5 00 a.m
drinking you know broccoli smoothies
eating avocado ice cream never having a
cheeseburger never throwing back a beer
having a one sip of tequila that makes
your weekend at bernie's at the super
bowl parade
it's it's
that's that's
how you do how do you do it every day
you do it every day by creating real or
imagined enemies that are constantly
conspiring against you that's it
i guess and i like that because it's
related in a weird sort of way it's
relatable because we all need that
reason to get out of bed every morning
and go do what we do that and he looks
for any reason he can if he has to make
it up he will
yeah exactly and you know what like we
said it works for him clearly you know
he's been to two ten super bowls and one
seven of them so i guess it just works
for him though i i did think it was
funny there i was watching one of these
super bowl pre-game shows and he was on
there with an interview i guess it must
have been on cbs because they had these
nickelodeon kids that were from that
broadcast that they did of the saints
bears game and they were interviewing
him and they asked him like when was the
last time you had a slice of pizza and
he said oh it was actually a couple of
weeks ago and i don't believe that for a
second
it was cauliflower crust
with uh with with cheese that was
manufactured from a fully organic goat's
milk
that that has only ever eaten
totally organic hydroponically grown
grass uh that is fed by i could just
keep going but yeah it's pizza it looks
like pizza but it's not made of anything
that would be in the pizza that you and
i would eat so uh i i'm really tempted
here to make a bunch of bad puns from
tom brady tom petty songs you pulled in
a couple naturally i'm going to pass on
the opportunity because the devil on my
left shoulder is screaming out a few
things and and he's going to lose at
least for now and matt casey's saying do
it
they weren't very good if they were good
i would have done them
i'll give in to the devil on the left
shoulder when it's good it's not worth
it so let's just take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports